no one is perfect at everything and
we're all made to be perfectly imperfect
I was rejected but it was the best
rejection ever for me to lead me in a
different direction the direction where
I'm heading towards right now you learn
way more when you fail than when you
succeed that's something I can guarantee
you on you want to tell stories and you
want something that can last longer than
just a one-hit wonder what's that
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe that you have the
ability to do something special that can
change the planet so to help you on your
journey today we're going to learn from
YouTube or an entrepreneur Michelle Phan
and my take on her top ten rules for
success rule number six is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys liked the best
I came from a mother and father who are
both immigrants didn't speak English so
I had to learn English on my own had to
learn it through TV and through school
and had to learn how to speak Vietnamese
at home everything that I know of today
I had to teach myself I had to learn
from other people bring on mentors and
also adapting silencing my mind and just
observing quietly and adapting to that
even when I was doing YouTube everyone
thought I was crazy everyone thought I
was stupid like they literally said oh
that's so dumb you can never make money
on YouTube why would you do that why not
just go get a corporate job I followed
the beat of my own heart and that beat
led me here
find your qualities instead of focusing
on the negative which I know can be hard
focus on the positive and it doesn't
have to be a physical thing maybe you're
amazing at Mario Kart or you're a
brilliant pianist an amazing painter a
singer you make for great grades at
school no one is perfect at everything
and we're all made to be perfectly
imperfect kind of like this crystal see
it's not perfectly cut like a flawless
diamond but it's beautiful in its own
unique way
there won't be another crystal like this
one and just like you it has many many
facets and you'll be discovering more of
them as time goes by and if you don't
think you have a quality just ask
yourself this simple question what am I
good at everyone is good at something
and if you don't know what it is well
take this opportunity to find it sign up
for cooking classes painting classes
learn how
play some sports pick up on a passion
and nurture it because this helps build
self-worth it gives you something to do
and strive for I was rejected but it was
the best rejection ever for me to lead
me in a different direction the
direction where I'm heading towards
right now and that was back in 2007 I
applied for a job at a Lancome counter
at a department store because I wanted
to I really wanted to work in the beauty
industry I wanted to be a makeup artist
and I wanted to empower women through
just the art of beauty and so I went in
they were looking for a sales associate
and I applied for the job I filled out
the application I did sit-down interview
I answered all the right questions I
mean they were very impressed with my
knowledge and my passion and the last
question she asked me was was have you
ever worked in sales and I said no I you
know I'm a waitress I used you know I
know how to host I know how to make
people feel good and I know how to
really understand and read the fine
lines and details of people present you
know like when you're waiting tables you
really have to see like what someone
wants without them needing to say
anything to you so it wasn't good enough
for her though because she said well
unfortunately we do need someone that
has experience in sales and I said but I
can learn you know like please give me a
shot you know like just give me a chance
I'm willing to learn and I know I can I
know I can sell beauty I mean I love it
I'm passionate about it
two weeks later I never got the call
back and I was really devastated because
you know it's a rejection it's it's
tough because I think we're all
programmed to wanting to have like
positive reinforcement and you know we
want positive reinforcement we want
people to say yes we always want yes I
mean know is such a a negative like we
feel like sometimes we think no is
something bad but sometimes we need
knows in our lives to kind of shift us
in a different direction you know I
always find that in life like the
universe there's always three answers
when you want something it's either yes
not yet or I have something better so in
this case
in this case I I knew that I knew that
there was going to be something better I
didn't take that rejection I didn't just
I didn't drop my love for beauty in fact
I opened another door for myself and
that was through YouTube my webcam and I
said you know what I may not be able to
have a job as a sales associate at a
department store or selling makeup but
at least I can still fulfill my passion
and beauty by filming these tutorials
and helping girls and inspiring girls to
try new beauty looks and that's what I
did and two years later Lancome calls me
and they wanted me to become their
official online spokesperson I realized
you know how do I've gone back in time
and and told myself hey you know what
this rejection is something that you
need to take and you you know it's not a
bad thing I think like you know that was
like the best thing that ever happened
to me was that rejection so I absolutely
agree with you Andrea like sometimes
rejection is a blessing in disguise what
do you do when you start a business but
it fails well hopefully you can learn
from all the mistakes all the good
things and all the bad things and
reapply it to your new business or
reapply it to your new job or your new
career destination look at Apple Apple
is one of the most prestigious bankable
companies in the world and they had a
lot of failures they had a lot of
launches that didn't work they had a lot
of things that just didn't click with
the audience and their customers but
that didn't stop them from having a
thriving business you learn way more
when you fail than when you succeed
that's something I can guarantee you on
I didn't prepare myself to become a
beauty guru it didn't just happen it was
something that I knew fit for myself I
started filming on YouTube on my webcam
in college in my room like just doing
makeup tutorials and now now like I work
with L'Oreal and I have like three
companies that I'm a CEO of so it's
incredible how that all happened because
I had a passion and it all started from
a webcam and it doesn't matter how small
your beginnings are
doesn't matter it just it just all that
matters is how big your passion is if I
had to choose one thing that really
motivates me that I can recommend to a
lot of young entrepreneurs it's having
that finding and understanding why
you're doing what you're doing you're
having a sense of purpose because often
times I meet so many aspiring
entrepreneurs and they have these great
ideas but they don't even know why
they're doing money should be a
byproduct of what you love to do I just
want to really inspire the youth because
I've always believed in teaching and
sharing not coming from an authoritative
point of view like you have to use this
or use that but this is what works best
for me and it might work best for you
and it doesn't work for you then just
comment let me know what works best for
you because there might be someone here
watching those that you can help
my biggest thing I would tell myself is
really to just focus on what makes you
happy really don't listen to what
everyone else is telling you like your
parents are pushing you in this
direction your friends are trying to get
you to do this
ask yourself look at yourself in the
mirror and ask yourself what do I want
for myself you know and that was when I
was growing up it was always me pleasing
my parents pleasing my friends trying to
fit in but I never once to ask myself
what makes me happy what do I want to do
and I think my biggest advice is really
just taking the time and really just
finding quiet time giving yourself
moments to reflect on on where you want
where you want to see yourself in the
next 10 years and really like being
really realistic not about I want to
impress my friends I want to have a nice
car and have an amazing career it's not
about what everyone else wants it's
about what you want I want to inspire
girls and show them that you don't have
to do one thing and stick with it like
if you're if you love music you don't
really need to be a musician if you're
not a good singer you can manage
musicians or you can work doing like
sound effects or stuff like that like
there's so many different things you can
do that you really love and for me mine
was beauty I loved art but I also love
beauty and I found a way to combine the
two together and create makeup tutorials
and show girls how to become their own
artist and become their own makeup
artist and in a sense teaching other
girls to wake up every day and and apply
a red lipstick to feel confident again
what I recommend usually when anyone is
starting on YouTube is to really focus
on storytelling because storytelling how
a longer shelf life than just doing a
funny viral video like you want to tell
stories and you want something that can
last longer than just a one-hit wonder
it's like any business you build I mean
before you start you have to know
exactly what are you selling what are
you projecting what's your message
what's your vision what's your brand
identity and from there you can work I
wanted to make this video to remind you
guys that it's okay to feel stressed
it's very natural but the thing is you
can't feel stressed all the time even
something like this the phone a machine
messes up and remember guys we also have
to charge these things they don't just
run on forever even they need a break
and so if something like a cell phone a
machine needs a break
imagine us we need to give ourselves
time to relax to recharge to find and
seek that inner peace this day and age
where everything is moving so fast and
we're always wanting to be in the know
we're trying to keep up with everything
there's this pressure to always be on
but there's nothing wrong with just
turning everything off
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because MJ illustrates
asked me to if there's someone you'd
like to vote on for the next top ten
check out the link in the description
and go and have your say finally I want
to give a quick shout out to Mary and
Lizzie who was my publisher from
pranking Random House Mary and thank you
so much for your support on this one
word book journey and I really
appreciate the picture you took on
Instagram and shared it with your
following as well thank you again so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
I know not everyone in the world has the
luxury to do their dream job because
they have to make money they have to
hustle they have to accept a job that
they might not want to do or they hate
every idea has a million different
roadmaps if you love origami have you
perhaps thought about going to
engineering learning coding developing
an app designing even there's so many
different paths that you can take and
there's no one size fit for all rule for
your dream job there's so many different
things you can do with your giftings if
you do have a dream job idea have that
as a goal but leave room for yourself to
grow and explore different options it's
easy just engage engage with your
viewers actually go out and talk to them
and show them that you are talking to
them and you aren't interested in what
they think you just really have to have
a two-way conversation with people who
are watching your stuff because
traditional media it was just a one-way
street with new media when you're
watching the content you start seeing
all these comments from other viewers
and that in itself creates a new content
too sometimes they're debating sometimes
they're adding value sometimes it's just
really funny comments but I think now
it's really just having a social aspect
to the content that you're creating
consciously think positive thoughts
especially during moments when you're
feeling down so take a deep breath and
remind yourself that life is too short
and you got to make the best of it
listen to music that will lift your mood
a good beat and sound has been proven to
help people in a positive way music and
sound has been known to help the growth
of plants that says a lot you want to
have a healthy habit of maintaining this
mental muscle but you also don't want to
overdo it everything in moderation
balance is key it's good to remind
yourself from time to time how worthy
and how you know awesome you are but you
also want to leave room to grow and
improve I
we can all change and evolve for the
better
[Music]